ورشه اعمال البناء وصلت الى مرحله متقدمه
يتاكد ابو فيصل من جوده العمل يزاول هذه
المهنه التي تتطلب قدرا غير يسير من الدقه
والجهد منذ ميعه شبابه
فيجني ابو فيصل مالا كثيرا من هذه الحرفه
التي لا تخلو من مخاطر
في رمضان ينتهي يوم العمل باكرا وقبل
ذهابه الى البيت يقصد ابو فيصل السوق
محدوده هي الخيارات في السوق
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
فاجور العمال تقارب ثلاثه دولارات في
اليوم وامام ارتفاع الاسعار يشتري ابو
فيصل ما هو ضروري لوجبه اليوم دون اعداد
مؤن او اقتناء كماليات
كلها في النار
وعمل اليوم
وبجي اضافية فوق المنه فوق طبقتها البلديه
والجابيات الماء والكهرباء كله قاعد بيطلع
عليها كسها
الحياه كلها كسرت كسر لورا ما في شيء جديد
اسوق عامر باصناف الماكولات الرمضانيه ابو
حذيفه يرتاد سوق الخضار بحثا عن اسعار
مناسبه
وهو مهجر من مدينه خان شيخون ولانه يعمل
موظفا يقسم الراتب بين ايجار البيت وحاجات
العائله
طبخه واحده مع شويه خضره يعني طبعا الوضع
غير مع الغلا ودخل يعني قليل ضعف الاقبال
على السوق يزيد متاعب الباعه
فهم يعملون وقتا اطول ويجنون مالا اقل
بخمسه حط ليرتين بطرس لما بتقول له الزبون
ما في او ما بصير
بخمس ليرات
لليالي رمضان اطعمه اعتاد السوريون عليها
يعرضها الباعه بافضل شكل
ويجهزونها في وقت مبكر لتلبيه حاجه السكان
البعيدين عن السوق اما العرقسوس
فله ركن اساسي في كل سوق يتمسك الباعه
بتقاليد المهنه تعبيرا ربما عن مقاومتهم
للظروف الصعبه التي تمر بها البلاد امام
ارتفاع الاسعار وتدهور احوال الناس يضطر
كثير من السوريين الى الاستغناء عن بعض
اصناف السلع والماكولات المعتاده في رمضان
او شراء كميات قليله منها لا تتناسب مع
عدد افراد العائله فالفقر يجبر الناس على
التخلي عن بعض عاداتهم صهيب الخلف الجزيره
ادلب